okay
i love spider-verse as much as the next
guy it's a great story it's fun it's got
some some crazy moments and adventures
but i'm kind of getting burned out
and i feel like some of you guys are
feeling the same way so we're gonna take
a break for the next couple days and
we're gonna focus some on some
non-spiderman related stuff specifically
this current run a really new run on
batman now here's the thing batman lost
me during future state i'm not even
gonna lie right like i sort of i fired
up future state like when they ended it
on the whole like uh ghost maker story
and they were like we're gonna go into
the future i read a couple issues we
covered a couple of a couple issues and
i was like i'm not feeling this um so i
figured i would just wait until future
state ended we knew tinyon's run was
gonna come to an end once like the
future state story arc and the follow-up
to ghost maker basically concluded and
then like joshua williamson was going to
come on as the new writer so this is the
beginning of joshua williamson's run is
it a reboot not at all but it's
basically a reworking and we can kind of
make sense of things as time goes on so
one of the big things to know that was
coming out of like future state and and
kind of the setup for all that is that
in future state it was in the future
which is basically uh really the the
events as they unfolded where like bruce
wayne was really his identity as batman
and kind of been thrown out there you
had what was called the magistrate who
was this guy that kind of ran like this
big you could call them a peacekeeping
force was the official name but they
were basically paramilitary they were
running gotham with an iron fist right
so like vigilantes were just not
tolerated it was very much a kind of
dystopian future right very orwellian
very 1984 and so of course the the run
of tenyon during the events and really
the aftermath of future state was to
actually cover the stories of like how
we got there it wrapped up pretty fast
ghostmaker's still around like he's
still there and in fact he actually took
clown hunter from the joker war story if
you guys remember him that young kid
that was a vigilante that was like
killing people who were dressing up as
the joker ghost maker took him and then
basically went to go train him and
batman's still here in gotham city and
so really and it's kind of the cool
thing about tinian's run it sort of just
kind of picks up after like everything
right and he kind of references
everything right you know doesn't really
give it to us on the nose but we can
even kind of trace this back to like the
new 52 and the court of owls right but
like essentially gotham's been through a
lot over the course of the last few
years
a lot has happened in the city of gotham
and so with the fall of the magistrate
and like the peacekeepers removed and
all that kind of stuff you know
peacemakers whatever with all those guys
gone that gotham is in a lot of ways
celebrating really in the the best way
it possibly can but of course you know
petty criminals are doing their thing
you know as petty criminals and so on
and it's kind of a funny thing because
the way the tenian writes this i'm not
even gonna lie it's a throwback to like
the old 1930s 1940s comics right the art
of course is starkly different but it's
a throwback to the old comics right when
you basically have to have a situation
where like these two guys are like
getting ready to you know break in and
you know burglarize and all that kind of
stuff and that one of them kind of looks
up and sees what looks like batman on a
rooftop and the other guy's like no man
it's just another gargoyle right like
whoever it was that that built this
whole city all that kind of stuff we're
obsessed with gargoyles so there's
literally gargoyles all over the place
it's not batman we haven't seen batman
for a little while you're being paranoid
everything's fine it like like batman's
got more important things than to worry
about us right he's dealing with like
the banes and the jokers and the
scarecrows and all the other heavy
hitters all the time right he doesn't
worry about two guys who are committing
like b and e right like he's just not
really worried about us until it turns
out it is batman
who comes swooping down on these guys
right and it's kind of the funny thing
these guys run for their lives right
normally in a batman comic batman's like
i am vengeance i am the knight i'm gonna
beat the hell out of you and then that's
that's kind of how his stories go right
like these guys just run like they just
flee like they literally go running to a
couple of cops who were just like
chilling and it's like man it's a really
slow night and like you know i heard
there's cake back in the office they
literally come running up on him oh
rustos they're like beating on the
windows for their lives trying to get
into the cop car and like one of the
cops was like what the hell
they're like what batman is like i don't
see anything it was batman we saw him
you know that kind of a thing so it is
it is a hilarious little moment right
where like you get to see criminals who
are so terrified of batman they just run
to the cops right so i guess batman's
really doing his job but following that
you pick up with oracle and then we get
a kind of full-on explanation of what's
going on here right now for those of you
guys who don't know and i don't know
anybody who doesn't know but for those
of you guys who don't know barbara
gordon's oracle right the way your
character played off we've talked about
this before in the aftermath of the
killing joke when barbara gordon was
shot and basically paralyzed that dc had
to try to kind of find a way to make her
character as compelling and interesting
as she was before while fitting in to
the narrative that they created so she
basically became like the eyes and ears
of the batman community and here's the
thing man like for a girl who just sat
in a chair and told like the bat family
what was going on fans loved oracle like
back at that point in time like people
who got on to dc comics at that point in
time oh they won't hear a word against
oracle like they they feel like she's
like the best character ever right you
go running up on one of those fans and
you're like yeah man barbara gordon
sucked when she was oracle all hands are
going to get thrown it's it's it's crazy
they love the character like they love
barbara gordon as oracle and rightfully
so because if i'm being honest she's
more interesting as an oracle than she
is is bad girl maybe it's because of her
stories whatever the case is but
basically she kind of says what we've
covered already right i mean she's like
batman's been through a lot right we're
like one of the most crime-ridden cities
in the world but she says we know how to
party and so she tells batman like maybe
you should kind of take the night off
too you know it's been ridiculously busy
a lot's gone on like more than usual and
so it's kind of a funny thing because
batman as you guys know is batman right
bruce wayne doesn't really take a break
and so it's one of those things where
oracle says okay fine well then maybe
tonight like we can just kind of rest
easy and then it turns out nope that's
not gonna work and the reason why is
because she says facial recognition
software tagged a handful of hired
killers speeding up town and they're
basically heading to the billionaires
club that's throwing a party and the
problem here is that the billionaires
club is basically throwing a party
dressed up as villains right like the
billionaires ball villains of gotham so
literally they're celebrating the
various villains that have just kind of
spread throughout gotham city and and
caused all kinds of problems now
honestly i don't really see the
difference between this and like the
restaurant that's like modeled after
superheroes which by the way the closest
i found to a restaurant like that is
called super chefs in ohio that place is
amazing do they have this sandwich
called the juggernaut it's like a waffle
like it's like two waffles right like
you make a sandwich out of like two
belgian waffles and you're just an
amazing breakfast sandwich it'll give
you the itis like you wouldn't believe
but it is so good it is oh my god that
sandwich was amazing super chef's was
cool but i have you got to see a
restaurant like that one that we've seen
in the comics where it's like the joker
takes your order and he's like would you
like fries with that you know like that
kind of a thing like people dressing up
as like heroes and villains and all that
kind of good stuff but nonetheless right
it's the city kind of celebrating
villains now the reality behind this is
it's not as though the billionaires are
like yeah man like the joker is like one
of the one of the best things ever in a
lot of ways it's kind of designed to be
a mockery because the wealthiest
individuals in gotham were oftentimes
the most common targets of various
criminals who were out there but the
thing about this is that batman kind of
takes offense to it to a degree but
oracle tells them like there are some
individuals here who just don't fit in
like they're supposed to right they're
not playing the part one they don't move
and talk like billionaires and two
they've got stuff like guns and so of
course you end up finding out that all
these guys are basically being led by
like firefly now as far as i'm aware
this version of firefly is ted carson's
not garfield lens of those of you guys
who don't know the difference garfield
lens was the original firefly right he
debuted back in 1952. uh he's og right
he's he's really really old school dc
tried to make him like really dark and
gritty post-crisis but in the new 52
when they rebooted ted carson's ended up
becoming the new firefly and then as far
as i'm aware they kept them over the
course of dc rebirth they didn't change
them or anything like that like they did
with a lot of other characters where
they set them back to like their
original iterations instead of like the
versions that we got in the new 52 but
as most of you guys who have been around
this channel know i kind of have a soft
spot for like crappy b-list villains i
can't help it right like ted carson was
basically some gold miner who gambled
away his family's money and then became
a criminal because of it there's nothing
special about this guy
he's got like every villain origin story
ever but i love the fact that he's just
like this b-list guy but it is a hold up
right so he's like like he's like
literally he busts in he's like all
right everybody reach for the ceiling
and keep reaching until you reach it and
then at that point like killer croc
comes out of nowhere and attacks
everyone as you guys know killer croc is
largely a brawler right i mean this guy
just punches really hard there's not
really much in the way of finesse when
it comes to killer croc more of a
wrestler than anything else and so we're
all these different henchmen who are
dressed up as villains right so this is
not actually two-face it's not actually
the joker it's not actually the riddler
or even catwoman it looks like it but
that's not necessarily the case that
basically like killer croc has somehow
become an expert in martial arts right
like you know instead of just like
throwing rocks at batman if you guys
remember that scene for batman the
animated series i threw a rock at him i
mean it was a really big rock like i
don't know if you guys you guys remember
that at all but like it it becomes quite
apparent to basically everybody there
that it's batman right and so of course
you know once the costume comes off and
then once firefly realizes batman he
begins to panic and like starts sending
his guys one by one to to take out
batman and batman of course is able to
incapacitate all of them he's able to
take these guys out not a whole lot
doing here i mean it's batman versus a
bunch of hired thugs i mean it's not the
most interesting thing ever but once all
these guys are taken care of and
everything's handled suddenly it turns
into hero warship right everybody's just
like yeah batman this is amazing and
it's one of those things
it's easy to miss here but it's one of
those things batman's not really used to
being celebrated even before the events
of like the magistrate and the the
peacekeepers and all that kind of stuff
back when it was like the new 52 or like
court of owls or something like that
batman was one of those concepts where
the city of gotham tolerated him but
didn't necessarily celebrate them right
because in a lot of ways the people of
gotham saw the rise of villains like the
joker is really a kind of direct result
of batman's actions right like in the
dark night it's like he pushed him and
pushed him until they turned to a man
they didn't fully understand and then as
a result of that just all hell broke
loose and so the perceptions of a lot of
people in the city of gotham is that
batman actually made the city worse
right before batman it was you had to
worry about getting robbed in crime
alley now the batman's here you gotta
worry about the joker flooding the whole
city with toxin and killing like a
thousand people right i mean he had to
worry about that kind of stuff on a
daily basis and so where he is is met by
all these people who are celebrating him
a little girl shows up dressed as that
one chick that dc tried to make into the
new harley quinn and nobody cared about
so they just can find her to a backup
story that nobody read i can't remember
her name and it doesn't matter because
like a year she'll be shuffled off to
the cornfields and no one will remember
her name anyway uh but like like this
look like this little girl's dressed up
as her and like runs them on batman and
batman's kind of like huh this is a
little weird and so he kind of has this
conversation right with like with oracle
where he's like i'm not used to this
right of course they end up wiping the
phones of everybody before they can post
pictures of social media and all that
kind of stuff so all they'll have is
their word there'll be no actual
evidence whatsoever but batman says like
i'm not used to gotham city celebrating
me and it's one of those things where
she's kind of like well i mean what do
you normally do when you solve some kind
of a case and all batman really does
it's it's relatively small and kind of
confined right like either he and jim
gordon kind of work on whatever the next
case happens to be he might celebrate
some small moment with like damian wayne
or he and superman might spend time
together but it's only ever a momentary
reprieve right it's like i've saved the
day cool i'm gonna go get some sleep
back at it tomorrow because like gotham
never rests right crime never rests in
the city of gotham so batman can never
really even get any rest and so what you
end up getting of course is oracle who
says hey man like you should come over
here right like dick grayson's coming
over right like come have brunch dude
relax chill for a little bit but then
something catches his eye only for us to
find out that members of batman
incorporated have basically been
arrested on charges of murder now for
those of you guys who don't know
anything about batman incorporated and
we can cover this we can cover batman
incorporated if you guys are interested
those of you guys who don't know
anything about this batman incorporated
was the follow-up in grant morrison's
run right so you had like grant
morrison's batman story you had like
final crisis batman thrown back in time
and you know the return of bruce wayne
storyline where he had to like find his
way back to the present day and all that
kind of stuff batman incorporated was a
story which was phenomenal and it was
basically written as a way where batman
essentially created a worldwide batman
organization right like you basically
had the batman family right so like
people who were modeled after the batman
character in different countries and you
even see that here right like batman of
china different things along those lines
but it was basically an attempt to
expand the roster out and kind of solve
a lot of the world's problems in some of
the most corrupted and crime-ridden
places and so the results of this is
that in more recent years especially
following joker war when bruce wayne
basically lost his fortune he doesn't
really have the money to essentially
fund batman incorporated anymore so it
all ended up kind of falling to the
wayside right like it essentially
disbanded and he never kept track of
them which is kind of a funny thing for
williamson to mention because in a lot
of ways neither did dc
right dc just kind of started telling
all these stories about batman it's like
where's batman incorporated well i don't
know
don't really keep track of him anymore
right like dc comics as a publisher
didn't really keep track of batman
incorporated and so what you end up
doing here is actually picking up with
detective kaya i think is how you
pronounce it c-a-y-h-a i'm not 100 sure
how to pronounce that so let me know
down in the comment section if i've got
it wrong but she essentially shows up to
the scene where there's like a guy right
it looks like a criminal named abyss
that was killed by batman incorporated
and it's one of those things where like
when she's there of course batman meets
her and so what you end up learning is
that with abyss seemingly he was part or
at least they were part of a larger
organization right we don't know if
abyss was a person or at least just a
singular individual or if it was like a
larger group it sounds like it's a
larger group because it's it's being
referred to or they're being referred to
as they right and so the statement we
get is that for the last year abyss has
basically been terrorizing uh bodnisia
right kidnapping people at least 20
people off the street that people were
afraid to go out at night and then
batman incorporated flew in to save the
day but they turned themselves in after
abyss's body was found by their
detectives and so just given the overall
crime scene right given the overall
depiction of this the response to batman
is no they're not being framed they
actually did it right like they killed
abyss and and detective kai is kind of
surprised you can tell this just by the
crime scene and batman's like i mean at
the end of the day like they were all
heroes so the question is what turned
them into killers that's what i really
care about you know i don't really care
about answering your questions i can
figure this all out so fast like i want
to know what led to them becoming
killers like something had to have
happened they were all influenced by
batman yes and they were all bankrolled
by bruce wayne that's true but the
reality of this is these guys were
heroes right they were part of like the
club of heroes that basically teamed up
from time to time but then they
disbanded and batman stopped keeping
track of them right so once they stopped
becoming batman incorporated they kind
of became their own group and then split
and so it's one of the funny things
where you know detective kai is like
yeah like they were they were funded by
that rich guy you know and then when
batman's like yeah bruce wayne you know
he no longer funds you know no longer
has the money to support their mission
she's like no no they weren't backed by
him they were backed by the other guy
right by that guy over there and that's
when this dude comes out of nowhere and
says after everything that happened in
gotham city someone had to pick up the
slack when wayne could not bring batman
incorporated out of the darkness and
into the light so they could truly help
make the world a better place but don't
mind me batman i'm just protecting my
investment only for us to find out the
person who basically took over funding
batman incorporated after bruce wayne
lost his money was lex luthor with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end i'm hyped for this story man
i'm not even gonna lie i'm pretty
excited about this but if you guys want
me to cover batman incorporated let me
know i mean this we've this is a monthly
comic right so we've got a few weeks
until the next issue comes out but let
me know what you guys think thank you
all for watching and i will catch you
guys later
peace